who resigned as a senior advisor to US
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo last week
is next in line to be questioned in the
presidential impeachment inquiry on
Tuesday a senior State Department
official in charge of Ukraine policy
testified before the committee
George Kent was questioned about his
knowledge of Trump's efforts to have
Ukraine investigate his political rival
Joe Biden our Democrats are accusing the
Trump administration of stonewalling the
inquiry well the head of the House
Intelligence Committee Adam Schiff says
evidence of obstruction of Congress
continues to mount we are running into
what we expected and one aspect and that
is a complete effort by the
administration to Stonewall today is
long past due the date when the State
Department was subpoenaed to provide
documents but the State Department has
thus far refused and were it not for the
fact that at least some witnesses have
given us documents we would not know
that there is a paper record of efforts
to condition this meeting and perhaps
condition military support itself on
these political investigations Donald
Trump wanted well Michael Isikoff is
chief investigative correspondent at
Yahoo News and co-author of Russian
roulette welcome to the program you did
write the book Russian roulette which of
course dealt with the so-called Russia
gaze and the mother inquiry and I'm just
wondering if you draw a line from that
to what we're seeing here and the impact
on Donald Trump politically does any of
this ultimately touch him or affect his
political base well yes and there is a
direct line from the Russia story to the
Ukraine scandal going on right now just
go back and look at the transcript of
the phone call between President Trump
and President Solinsky
what is the first matter that Trump
raises after he says I want you to do me
a favor he wants Solinsky to look into
supposed Ukrainian interference in which
thousands of socialists of attempt to
get people to investigate Hillary
Clinton of course and
you know he wants he wants the
Ukrainians to find the server that was
used at the DNC the only purpose of that
is because President Trump has is still
unable to accept the findings of the US
intelligence community the US law
enforcement community the Congress the
robert muller investigation that it was
the russians who hacked the DNC that's
why he's obsessed about this server he
thinks somehow that's going to refute
all the conclusions of all the agencies
that have investigated but when he says
this is a witch hunt this is the
democrats coo right people listening to
him yeah political base those who were
rusted on and going to vote for him
those who put him in the White House are
they are they saying yes of course it is
look I think the polls are gonna be
extremely important here as this goes
forward we've already seen an increasing
number of Americans according to the
polls who support at least that
impeachment inquiry it's now over fifty
percent that's a pretty substantial
increase and it suggests that the tide
is turning somewhat against the
president whether it's gonna be enough
to sustain a impeachment and removal
we'll just have to wait and see but it's
clearly the evidence has been mounting
here breaking the impeachment and
removal is a high bar just of course
then you're talking about the Senate and
two-thirds right you know is that that
could be a step too far but is what we
are seeing in these hearings right now a
really critical development in that it
isn't Democrats who were raising alarms
here
it's people like Fiona Hill right worked
for him he's Russia expert it's people
like John Bolton national security
adviser rights the former ambassador to
Ukraine these are people inside the tent
does that shift the narrative somewhat I
think somewhat if you remember that the
president tried to make this about the
whistleblower who's the whistleblower
did he have a political and political
agenda but when you see this parade of
witnesses
Fiona Hill is mr. Kent some of the
others I think that shifts it away from
the whistleblower and puts it
you know career people who don't have
political agendas who were working for
the president like the former ambassador
who was removed now I should be behind
things right okay can I just ask you
though about how this plays out with the
Democrats particularly as we see the
debates continue and obviously there's
unified position on wanting to push
ahead with the impeachment in these
investigations but what effect does it
have on Joe Biden is this some lead in
his saddlebags yeah like I said well I
think I think it is I think he you know
he continues to get asked about his
son's service on that board
that of the company burr is my while he
Biden was serving as the point person
for the Obama administration
I think this clearly has wounded Biden
Elizabeth Warren is now almost
universally seen as the front-runner in
the race we're six weeks ago two months
ago Biden was so I think it's taking its
toll I should just want to make one
other point you know we've talked about
these hearings remember so far they've
all been behind closed doors and I think
that that's given the Republicans a
talking point and at some point Schiff
is going to have to open up release the
transcripts of those depositions and
hold public hearings if he wants to make
the case if the Democrats want to make
the case that impeachment has to take
place here welcome pleasure to have you
on the program any time